as Kanye West's controversial week
continues he makes time to shout out a
crush
on Thursday the rapper revealed he's got
a thing for Kylie Jenner's bestie Stasi
this would be really cute so cute
over on the gram yay posted this pic of
Kylie from Paris fashion week and claims
in the caption he helped her Squad get
into a coveted runway show quote okay
okay okay I'll admit I got Johan to
sneak Anastasia Victoria and Carter into
the Balenciaga show and yes the whole
world knows I got a crush on stas stas
is Stasi who fans know as a close friend
of the Kardashians or as Kanye calls
them in his message the Calabasas Mafia
straws I almost hit that car I know you
really need to be careful
stasis yet to respond to Kanye's post
but when it comes to crushes Kanye's
boasted a few since his split from Kim
in February 2021. I call him my
boyfriend and he calls me his girlfriend
yep the rapper briefly dated Julia Fox
earlier this year but they split just a
few weeks after are you still in touch
with Kanye at all we're still friends
yes but it's nice to end on friendly
terms yeah always he was later spotted
spending time with Cheney Jones you know
the model who looks eerily similar to
his ex I think you have to have a sense
of humor back in the City of Lights
Kylie and Khloe Kardashian were on hand
to support yay's modeling debuted
[Music]
outside he struggled to speak while
donning a Balenciaga mouth guard
but that wasn't his most headline-making
moment of the week
no that was his white lives matter shirt
which he wore alongside polarizing
conservative commentator Candice Owens
at his Yeezy runway show black lives
matter released their 990 IRS filing
later sharing this clip to his Instagram
story they collected 80 million dollars
super frustrating but that's a dead end
so
the moment was slammed all across social
media by fans and celebrities alike
Kanye clapped back writing why did
everyone feel so free to attack me about
my t-shirt but Candace Owens was the
only public figure to say that it was
wrong for the Kardashians to keep me
from seeing my daughter yeah that
incident happened back in January when
he allegedly wasn't allowed to attend
his four-year-old Chicago's birthday
party most men do not there's no such
thing as 50 50 custody with with and
society today that's not that's not even
it always leans towards the mom
Chloe responded to that post pleading
quote again with the birthday narrative
enough already we all know the truth and
in my opinion everyone's tired of it
adding please stop tearing Kimberly down
and using our family when you want to
deflect own whatever it is
[Music]